(crowd cheering enthusiastically)
- [Jonathan] China celebrated
the 100th anniversary
of its ruling Communist party on July 1st.
(cannons banging)
This anniversary is really a moment
for the Chinese Communist
Party to be able to look back
on how far it's come, from a party
that was more or less ruled
out as a potential power player
into the driving force behind the country
that is now the world's
second largest economy
and on pace to be its number-one economy.
Xi Jinping really wants
to take this moment
and say China has arrived.
(Xi speaks in foreign language)
(audience applauding)
- [Jonathan] Nobody thought
that the CCP would be this successful
when it was founded in 1921,
whether it be in science,
technology, in sports and the economy.
In almost every facet, China is stronger
than it's been in the
past and, in a sense,
they're really gonna give
the U.S. and the West a run for its money.
- We're in a race with China and the rest
of the world for the 21st century.
They're not waiting, they're
investing tens of billions
of dollars across the board.
- But to surpass the U.S.,
China will have to overcome
several challenges.
(people murmuring)
This is a time when China's
economy is recovering
from the coronavirus pandemic
earlier than everywhere else
and that's left China
looking pretty strong.
Its economy is expected
to grow by 8.5% this year,
and it was gaining ground
not only in the U.S.,
but it was adding ground
between itself and many of its neighbors.
It was able to take advantage
of the demand for exports
all around the world
when people needed PPE,
when people needed medical equipment,
when people needed computer equipment.
It's made big leaps in mobile payments,
artificial intelligence,
quantum computing,
and even sending a rover to Mars.
(triumphant music)
So part of the strength
of the Chinese state
over the last 30 to 40 years
has been based on its economy.
It's grown so quickly and
with a massive population
it had both a large base of labor
as well as a huge market
for Western companies
and other foreign companies
to move into China.
What we're starting to
see now is that some
of that economic growth is
slowing, mainly you have
a population in China that
is skewing older and older.
Chinese demographers believe
that China really has about
a 10, 15-year window here
before things start to
get really bad in terms
of the number of people
that you have working,
trying to support X number
of people who are retired.
So one of the measures that the
Chinese government has taken
was to allow Chinese
people to have more babies.
That's because for the better
part of the last four decades
China has restricted most
families to only having one child.
(guns banging)
One of the most important
priorities for Xi Jinping
has been ensuring that
China's periphery is secure.
It has Xinjiang, it has Hong Kong,
and we've seen very strong
controls put in place there
over the past few years
to really make sure
that Beijing's will is first and foremost.
Beijing has drawn global
scrutiny for its use
of surveillance technology to keep an eye
on people's activities in
Xinjiang and Hong Kong.
Beijing has said that
national security concerns
in Hong Kong have required it
to take stronger measures in the city.
Chinese authorities have
defended the use of surveillance
in Xinjiang as designed to promote
development and security for locals.
- They have an overall goal
to become the leading
country in the world,
the wealthiest country in the world,
and the most powerful
country in the world.
That's not gonna happen on my watch.
- [Jonathan] Biden's rhetoric
has actually been very tough
since he became president and he has said
that genocide is what is
happening in Xinjiang.
- DHS is deeply concerned by
credible and growing reports
of China's state-sponsored
use of forced labor
and other human rights violations
in the Xinjiang region.
(Zhao speaks in foreign language)
- Biden has said that, in
contrast to his predecessor,
he wants to work with other
democracies to stand up
to autocratic governments like China's.
It seems like in Washington
Biden has now reflected
and captured the zeitgeist there
that says China is
fundamentally different from us
in terms of their values and
they're gaining ground on us
in a way that we should
be very worried about.
Over the next 10 to 15 years,
Xi has made it very clear
that he wants to build self-sufficiency.
I think he's recognized
that China's too reliant
in some ways on the West in
areas like semiconductors
and technologies with
military applications,
and China is definitely
doing things in its own way.
It's stepped up control of big
and powerful tech companies,
such as the fintech giant
Ant and how it handles
the user data that it generates.
(Xi speaks in foreign language)
- [Jonathan] What Xi Jinping
says and wants is for China
to be able to keep its prosperity
but also be more ideologically committed
to the Communist underpinning
that first inspired
the founders of the Communist
Party here in China.
(audience applauding)
He also wants a country
where the people are gonna be
more loyal to China than
they have been in the past.
(gentle music)